there's a challenge on the right right
now like what does the right want to be
what does a broad conservative let's say
Coalition want to look like does it want
genuine racists to be part of it or does
it want to be a little more mature does
it want to have some leadership that
knows how to stand up to people and
knows how to Enlighten people on what
actual individual rights and American
values are anyway Kanye continued going
after Ben Shapiro and Ben Shapiro I
don't know if you know this he's Jewish
it is true Kanye found uh well
apparently this tweet has since been
deleted by Kanye but Kanye wrote Shapiro
starvingly accepts a hundred thousand
from one of my opponents then tries to
trash me what he's referring to there
what you're seeing there is that
apparently Iran DeSantis Super PAC not a
Ron DeSantis pack but a Rhonda Santa's
Super PAC which they're not associated
with the campaigns they apparently put a
whole bunch of money into advertising on
The Daily wire so when is from one of my
opponents he's calling Ron DeSantis
one of his opponents because Kanye wants
to run for president which might be why
as I just said he wants to take out
Donald Trump uh Ben Shapiro saw that
tweet and said sadly you've trashed
yourself you didn't need my help it
wasn't me it wasn't the Jews it was just
you and that really is right I don't
blame anyone else for Kanye's Behavior
other than Kanye I don't blame anyone
else other than Milo or the swinte's guy
or whatever and by the way These Guys
these are people who have said
horrifically awful things about me I am
not demanding that they be taken to the
gulag or anything else but they should
be ignored and mocked and I don't know
not part of
decent Society like and that's not
that's not oh we have to have these
guard rails on society and really watch
what people say uh no if you're like
genuinely racist and you really want
different laws for different people uh
you can't you can't play with the adults
that's how it is they shouldn't be
censored they should just be ignored